yo yo you already know it's your boy Ace
AKA Don Pablo fortune favors the bowl
out right now catch me on that bootleg
cab podcast my brother he shot third
game
all right man look it's the bootle cap
show we got a special guest in here my
guy Dave East my brother we back baby
how you been I've been good man we're
just talking about how uh we are not far
in age and you were surprised
because you pretty much said white
people age like [__] no I that that that
did not leave my [__] mouth I
thought you you just I said I'm you know
what it is is I feel like you have a
maturity about you it ain't how you look
it's about your Vibe you just feel like
you feel like
I was born the year before damn I
thought you were Oh I thought you was
older bro yeah well I thought it was
like 85 84. you know what I mean we same
era we went through this Nickelodeon all
the same age like milk bruh
we were black on the same [__] like
don't crack yeah you know drink water
man I I always my best advice is water
and cocoa butter the white people do
white people use cocoa butter no I
jerked off with it before
too much too TMI I have like as a kid I
think it was at the house and my hands
smelled like chocolate all day no it's
good for you it's good for your skin
he's sick Drew your haircut
because sick I love cocoa butter though
it's good for you the stretch marks it's
good for your skin if you have stretch
marks cocoa butter then wounds you know
as you know as a uh as kids we also I
was outside a lot falling off bikes and
[__]
getting in fights and shoes so a lot of
my blemishes and scars
big shout out to um the cocoa butter you
heard shout out to the cocoa butter uh
you are a pretty healthy guy in general
I would say right
um
what is your like Diet regimen like
these days
um how do you look young you know what's
crazy with me I don't really have a diet
I just don't eat no pork
so you don't eat the swine no no Swan
stop for law I don't know no no no no I
stay far away from now okay I'm Muslim
you know that okay but um
yeah I I stay far away from pork
um I eat a lot of seafood
I love Seafood uh what about red meat
you have a steak I like steaks like if
my moms make it or if we had a flavor
restaurant or some [__] like that I
might order a steak depending on my mood
but I kind of I don't really I don't
over indulge as much as I did in my 20s
in red meat as I do I mean like I fell
back over with any vitamins it's like
CMOS or anything um CMOS uh bladder rack
all that um black seed oil bladder rack
what's that mean it's like a um I hope
I'm saying it right big shout out to
Styles P
with the pharmacy I take that ride up
you know what I'm saying go up there and
they give me a whole uh like a Christmas
package a healthy [__] for me my kids
you got the he got the the tablets or
the healthy [__] CMOS and all that that
tastes like candy for the kids so me and
my kids I'm big on
I'm just big on health bro and not
getting sick and catching colds and I'm
saying like you really can't be active
out here if you if you sneezing and all
that type of [__] did you uh catch covet
when it was running around I actually
did catch it shouts to my brother doc I
don't wanna blow dot spot up but I think
that [__] dot gave me cover you heard
or the mother was it a rough go
um I just couldn't taste nothing and it
was Thanksgiving oh the worst time
nothing like or so my mom's getting busy
I couldn't smell nothing can't taste
nothing let's talk about the word that's
the single worst time you could have got
covered that was terrible bro it was to
the point where like you know when you
taking a [__] you could you smell your
[__] like well you're [__] like you know
what's crazy I couldn't smell my [__]
that's how I knew I had so it had me
scared cab like you know what I'm saying
you don't know if a joints if you don't
know if breath stinks I'm not gonna be
talking to you right in your face [__]
bro you don't even know that like you
just dugging it out like what's up bro
like yeah my dog took over this nasty my
dog [__] on the floor
and I didn't smell it couldn't smell
nothing and I was like
and that [__] probably was rocking no
right and so I was like
this was like well nothing June of 2020
so I'm like oh [__] I got kovitz that's
what I called it 20 20. so then I held
it up and I was like oh yeah I don't
smell anything this is crazy I had it
for like nine ten days my best friend
died
um May 5th 2020 shooter God bless his
soul you best shooter I brought him here
and then my daughter was born my second
daughter Kobe my little badass November
11th 2020. so I caught it like right
when she was born type [__] so when I
brought her from the hospital back to
the crib
I think that's when um
um the ps5s and all that was just coming
out I was slinging it you know yeah my
man I had a little homie had him in the
hood yeah and my core my son died like
yo bro bring me over here let's get the
PS5 for my little man
when dot pulled up he's sweating mine he
was like cold outside what's up with you
you drink like now I'm good he coughing
and [__] I'm like man you know I've been
watching the news yeah everyone at that
time I was like that you know yeah there
ain't no regular cold man watch them
sneezes and all that [__] watch your
hands watch all that you feel me come to
find out
me and him like bro I ain't gonna front
let's go to Urgent Care bro me and you
like I feel you got me feeling Wicked
already bro we went over there and I
took two tests they had the um the rapid
[__] and it was negative I was like all
right I'm Gucci and then they did the
real one the [__] that take like 10-15
minutes to [__] when they put it up in
your house I went through all that with
it they was putting them shits in your
brain and they all went through that hey
man we went to Jamaica they did that
[__] they put that [__] in my in my
forehead I'm like yo this is crazy pause
but
I I caught it but I had it nine ten days
got off and I ain't catch it again I
never got the um you never got jabbed
nine did you miss out on any
opportunities because you decided not to
be vexed
um
by the way kudos to you I don't think so
not pressuring to the social
pressure of yeah you know what you know
what it is bro by the way I pressure to
it I'm into my mom's and my dad did but
they older so I kind of respected what
they were saying just because they you
know they both 70 years old they've said
now like if you're like in good health
and you caught it it was better immunity
than the vaccine because then you're
just catching it yeah your body fight it
off gangster that's like any cold like
the flu anything you caught before
anything I caught bro like like chicken
pox you from that area yeah the Chicken
Box kids don't catch that noise you get
it once and it's done but if you
scratched it remember they used to say
especially I see people today got mad
chicken pox because they were scratching
that [__] calamine lotion
anytime you get a bug bite calamine
my mom's used to put us in a bath and
and Lace Us in Calamine you know what I
never used with Calamine I never use
Calamine with the porn like I did the
cocoa butter yeah I hope the [__] not
man yeah that's good
do you still do you still like
for exercise purposes or just for fun do
you still ever hoop
I haven't played ball in a while I'm not
gonna lie to you you know I'm I keep it
real like all the time I tell people
I really played basketball like I see a
lot of rappers now I feel like they got
rich and famous and successful right and
now it's like a it's a hobby or a free
time thing and like I played like Drake
like when everybody was a [__] Arena
at his house so it's like Kudos big
shouts to Drizzy that's you know that's
that's a [__] from the hood dream to
have a [__] no gym in your crib it's
like his own League at his house you
know what I'm saying like I I wouldn't
know how to get [__] out my house if I
had that they'd be spending the night in
the gym but I already know the Vibes at
the end of the day it's like
with boy I really did that bro from from
from four or five years old to
I got locked up to 21 right like
non-stop I wasn't trying to rap I wasn't
did you do AAU or was that a thing
everything everything that came with AAU
I did all that assembly summer
tournament everything like that was my
life until
it wasn't my life right you know what
I'm saying but I always had a love for
rap like I've said so many times like
you know I mean but that was like I can
remember playing ball and watching Meek
Mill freestyle and when Mick was getting
this [__] together in Philly and he was
doing all them freestyles and I remember
that but I was hooping right you know
what I'm saying mooc shouts the murder
Moog Loaded Lux or them like from Harlem
they was inspiring me with the smack
during the whole Smack DVD right Great
era crazy era but I was playing
basketball so you were you were like I
wasn't I was a fan of that [__] I wasn't
rapping so for me to jump in the game
when I did
after they eat and kind of laid the
blueprint or they've been in it so long
and still get the recognition I got you
know what I'm saying that I'm getting
it's a blessing 100 man
um for you
uh this album you have some West Coast I
mean you've always been super tapped in
in L.A but like I love Cali you know
that not it feels like it's definitely
your second home you know that and
you've been embraced by California
heavily from day one you got tiger and
uh young Gerald on the uh See Red Dog
and G-Eazy and you know what's crazy
about this album like I didn't I've said
this to the homies but everybody
delivered bro every feature it's gonna
be better you're Dave East but they but
but still but you know sometimes they'll
just be like all right people just give
you a verse yeah I've dealt with that
like if if it's like you sending this on
like damn now I gotta come with me you
know I'm gonna talk I'm talking so at
the day you don't want to just get burnt
on the record but at the same time it's
almost like
them is part like the tiger record and
the G-Eazy record ain't really no
lyrical
rep type of joints like we those is kind
of more fun right you know what I mean
like but they delivered if you put a big
shout out you put tiger on like a random
Alchemist beat I'd be just gonna talk
I'd be disappointed but but nobody I
don't feel like that's what you want to
hear like I don't think when I heard the
beat actually you know what I do want to
hear that me too I want to hear tiger
and Alchemist do five songs EP challenge
to the outcome tiger can rap bro I feel
like people don't understand that he
came up under Lil Wayne I don't know one
of the one of the greatest Weezy one of
the greatest bro you don't think I can
rap
I mean he can rap like like rap oh but
you're just so used to hearing him on
certain type of [__] you know what he
had a song Tiger kid spit bro his first
album he had a song in his album
like really can spit and I'm a [__]
people that rap I don't know so his
first album the one that rack city on it
he did have a song with Big Sean and a
song with Nas and he kept up with them
on both records for sure I'll say that
but but this is what I learned
is that me oh that's my Android right
that's true man what's called my Android
[__] you should jump in man hotline man
that's like my old old number I learned
this in this game bro you got to go with
what what the people love him and I'm
saying a lot of times and you got to go
with
was feeding your family you got to go
what's what's what's making in life how
you want it to be so if this is winning
that's why I love like I'm gonna do
what's winning 100 I salute them Tyler
got to do that [__] all day same thing
when like when Flo Rida was like kind of
like came in with po boy and then he
caught a wave and Flo Rida's like I'ma
just do pop records and I'm like bro I
ain't mad at you and look what he look
how he ran it up he just bought Celsius
I know he sued Celsius for like 40
million dollars he ran it big shot out
the Flo Rida he ran it the [__] ran it
up I'm a fan of [__] running the [__]
up like 100 I'm a fan of that uh anybody
knew you like it like that you're a fan
of right now that you're maybe outside
of anyone you're like directly
affiliated with but like anybody who
just noticing what they're doing and you
appreciate it in the music game
um new newer folks yes
ah let me see
um
who's new right now that I feel like
it's Simba Simba is hard Simba's fire
December talk he pulled up shouts the
melies my brother Blanco he brought him
out on on the last tour I had any you
know what else I like like Beyond rap
bro like I know a lot of [__] that can
rap with me it'd be about like who you
are as a person when I meet you or you
know I'm saying like a lot of the most
solid a lot of people pull up and they
like a like a like a superhero or their
character yeah bro take off the rappers
yeah they didn't put it in them like I
like people that's just them bro like no
matter how dope you all what you got
going on just be yourself cause I'm
always myself like in any environment so
he's somebody that really caught my eye
I'm in tune with him
um
I'm trying to think
uh uh that's new damn
I feel like it's a few that's how that's
hard
but I'm really thinking about who really
like talking like he wanted him that's I
feel like that's talking like as far as
on some lyrical [__] you know
um you probably had to shoot some names
out I feel like certain names I'm gonna
say I already worked with type [__]
somebody who I think you'd like
who shares the same uh love for the
color blue is uh
big X the plug he's from Houston or he's
from Dallas Texas big extra plug he
talking he fired he's like my favorite
rapper he's [__] you got some [__]
with him I'm gonna tap him no I gotta
meet him he's just this big dude who
[__] just be [__] I'm gonna
definitely tapping I'm one of them that
being so much in my own world bro like
it don't be a knock to nobody but I
gotta get put on this [__] like you know
what I'm saying like a lot of [__] I got
put on to through the homies or
just people around me be like yo check
this out so you know what I mean once I
tap in then I'll be like oh that [__]
hard you know what I'm saying uh what is
something you learned from
putting out
a project that West Side gun executive
produced
because I think he actually
um what's the word eh
what's the word I'm looking for uh
key to the art Direction he curated the
cover he curated the cover for half a
big shout out to Harry Fraud uh one of
my favorite producers so he's an
executive producer album no no oh I
don't know why I thought executive that
was me and Harry me and Harry said and
that was during the pandemic so we
didn't even really
um get a chance to really sit down
together like that [__] was kind of
through zoom and [__] like that email
and [__] like I'm in the stool the
laptop I'm talking like he like we
together but we ain't together like you
know I'm saying like we had the camera
and [__] like that roller but that's
really how we did half it was the the
cover [__] was out I reached out the
West Side that's the homie Benny Conway
or risotto that's family you know what
I'm saying but um
I know he [__] with the art and I'm a
fan of the art
I just don't like with the actor I don't
I didn't know how to get into that
somebody had to like pull you in you
know hey you're perfect for this role
exactly and then I was like oh this I
was waiting for some [__] like this same
with the art I love art but I don't
really know
um how to get into that and I know west
side is on that [__] bro
let me put this cover together bro like
I'm doing some [__] called Hot Fuzz me
and Harry Fraud Benny on this [__] like
you know what I'm saying let's make it
make sense and then he um invited us up
to Buffalo
it says gallery and [__] like that in
the mall yeah it has no yeah yeah big
shout out there I was I went out there
now they solid bro like I respect they
hustle you gotta remember like me being
from New York City like all my life
nobody never spoke about Upstate
besides jails like you knew because
that's where you were to go to jail go
upstate yeah if you go up if you go up
top you go up top like you get what I'm
saying like so for them to do what they
did and really bring the whole world to
to they town and speak stories about
where they from I salute them [__]
forever yeah shout out to those guys uh
how dope is it for you to see your boy
Millie's just thriving out here man you
guys obviously
I love it bro and I knew it the whole
time like project together yeah you know
what's crazy big shout out to set free
you know I'm saying that that really
bridged that connected that you know
what I'm saying like back back before
this [__] really was cracking for me
like we met in the Bronx
at the original compound that said
freehand you know I'm saying
and Millie's from day one
um he hungry yeah you know I mean I
respect hungry like like people that's
really embedded in the culture it ain't
about the jewelry like I love to see
somebody glow up but that ain't it ain't
really about that right you know as time
go on you make more money you advance
you're gonna you're gonna do you're
gonna look a little different right but
he still stick to the script of what we
got into this [__] for you know what I'm
saying like he the reason I went to
Columbia
like I love I love Millie's how was
Colombia
you ever been there no I think I heard
it
lots of cocoa butter will be used
all that like I love Colombia bro like I
really spent time in Medellin
um working on this actual album and then
me and Millie's did our man videos for
um in Columbia yeah and one of Pablo's
stash houses really
what were the women like out there
indoor pool the women were gorgeous and
they ain't really speak no English and
[__] like that you hear about like do
you know what have you heard of a
passport bro what's the passport a
passport bro what's the passport bro
it's just like this [__] going violence
so this is what it is right it's like
dudes from the United States
who might not
stand a chance to get the level of [__]
they're gonna get in right places like
Columbia or Bangkok Thailand or whatever
and then they go and they like get a
chick from over there
and like if you just look up hashtag
passport Bros they'll be like an old
white dude with like a fine ass Latin
Shake it'd be like check out my new wife
passport Bros
I see I'm in tune with that I ain't
doing no pride no passport bro [__]
though they were out there though the
Bros were out but it was love like we
got to the crib they had the homies with
the AK-47s I know I was safe they was
looking out for us everything was
secured we had the pool indoors I'm with
the Griselda Blanco Hood shot a video
over there jeez I was in the trenches
over there uh I go to the trenches
everywhere I go Jamaica La what are you
Miami where do you enjoy vacationing the
most
um if I had to really choose like if
you're gonna not go to the trenches you
just want to relax Barbados Barbados
yeah that's my fault I'm Beijing you
know I mean my my father's father is
from Barbados so I think that's the most
um
for me peaceful
we I don't really get too much right and
if all the women look like Rihanna God
bless us
I don't think they all look like Rihanna
and Barbados you know they they say if
you go to Australia all the women look
like Iggy Azalea in Australia I wouldn't
know I was supposed to go out there you
know Australia I'm still coming out
there don't worry about it I'll be there
they [__] it's just such a long flight
it's a long I think it's the longest
flight that might be longer than Japan
in Japan it is long enough it's that
it's proven in Japan right
and they got the craziest [__]
Wildlife there kangaroos and all that
good [__] and spiders and sharks and
[__] and
they got Iggy Azalea you know what I
mean Iggy Iggy fire
she's she's uh yeah she's fire you can
fire she's like fire in the same way
like tigers fire like
I shouldn't do that
I don't know what I feel like you heard
different music than from him than I
heard tiger been fine bro he's always
been hot to me bro no he's hot
everything he always did was a was a Bop
bro like
I [__] with him like that's my guy he's
got all the Bops rack city [__]
appreciate him on that beginning on the
album
I [__] with tiger tiger good [__] uh
solid [__] you and J Stone never
dropped your project or am I trying Nate
ball Stone did you guys end up dropping
the project together
there's some new [__] me and stone will
put it together that's only right
that's only how many songs do you guys
have that you're sitting on like hard
drives we gotta tape so it's just a
matter of we gotta say but don't be
dropping I'll be dropping he drops a lot
for sure you know what I'm saying like
but that's that's family like out of all
of the rappers that you know what I'm
saying like I met or I really crossed
paths with me and stone got a different
type of vibe and of course it came from
from nip but we got our own type of
energy type [__] I love stone is it
pretty crazy like
[__] how many years has it been since we
lost nip was it I was 18. February it
was like early 2018. I was March 31st
right before April Fool's 2019 19. yeah
because it was after reaction that we
got a year before shooter so that was
like yeah 19.
um but to just see like how he's kind of
become this like I mean he was always a
legend but he's like a real icon like I
just like we're talking about one of our
interviews Clips just randomly going
viral I just saw Malcolm X you can dive
into like Nipsey reels of interviews
that he's had and just get life lessons
nobody was paying that [__] no mind
while he was here for sure but now you
know I mean that's it's sad that they go
that way but
he really
he really knew what was going on and and
knew how to do this [__] I feel like
more than a lot of people bro a lot of
people jump into this [__] and let the
money or the labels or the or the or the
fame direct how they move like I feel
like I feel like cuz had his own
blueprint on how he wanted to do it you
know I mean like beyond all that extra
[__] like he had his own
I'm gonna do it like this I'm gonna put
these [__] on that I grew up with I'm
gonna start my own [__] I'm gonna do the
store I'm gonna have my brother running
the store like he just had he had a lot
of insight on [__] that like a lot of
[__] don't got and I learned a lot
from him that I applied on my own [__]
right now you know what I mean how is uh
you you kind of are also becoming as
well known as an actor as you are an
artist because there's some people who
discovered who you are through acting
Who acting facts
um obviously you're a [__] rapper
you're a rappers rapper but like uh how
a lot of [__] are you diving in on the
acting all the way all the way that's
the [__] that had an old white ladies in
the in the in the airport
like [__] that I didn't get from rap you
know with rap I already certain [__]
with rap like I know if I walk in this
Popeyes you know someone's gonna know
this predominantly black or Spanish like
somebody gonna spot me like but when I
go through the airport and there's like
an older white lady or the younger Asian
kid or you know I mean like it just be
so many different
races that you know I mean that that
that tapped into me acting and I feel
like it just kind of like
brought in my rap [__] even more like it
kind of just built this [__] like it put
it out more are you like going well [__]
are you on strike right now
strike one for acting are you on strike
I ain't on no strength are you a part of
sag after I'm more sag but I ain't yeah
you're on strike you didn't even know it
you're stuck right now hey Dave you're
on strike man I'm hot I'm ready to act
what you talking about no no you're not
don't say that babe you cannot cross
pick you can't cross the picket line
you signed a waiver already
it's on me too that's crazy that means
you're on strike you know they hold down
your dental you know all that good [__]
they take care of the benefits that's
why you got to stand with sag that's the
union you heard
so I must be on strike you're on strike
you must be on strike you'll go go tune
in the Wu-Tang man it's three seasons of
that [__] and I did Beats big shout out
to Chris Robinson Anthony Anderson
uh they put me in my first film that I
have a Netflix movie right yeah that was
the first film I did Big shout out to
Gabrielle Union she put me on um uh the
Mary Jane on BT that was early are you
trying everybody that that that that
helped me get into that big big shout
out to them
all the time I do matter AJ always
sending me auditions and [__] like that
but I was saying before like I was
telling the homie like
I'm more into the like you know
directors know who they want in the
movie you can audition on you for the
most part yeah I mean but for the most
part you gotta like wow somebody you
gotta change their mind they know who
they want right you know what I'm saying
so I'm more into that like you know what
I mean I got a lot of [__] going on I'm
a fall of a rapper
I own a store there's a lot I got going
on so I'm not against the auditions East
Coast I got the pain you know we got
pain out here in these streets but I got
a lot going on so I'm more into the like
not East I see you for this role right
then I'll do the audition but I know you
already got me in mind for that you know
what I'm saying instead of me just like
yo let's try to go get that like right
right I ain't doing that is there fake
eastco in New York they bootlegging
everything Kev yeah well I asked because
I was in Detroit
Detroit we're selling uh bootleg empty
bags of this you could buy to stuff your
weed in and like this you know that's
but I'm gonna be real with you I seen uh
I watched I was why I was on YouTube I
seen Tupac get mad about bootlegging
uh who else I've seen Capo big bro Jim I
see I've seen a few people that that
don't like that right are you liking
this [__] or what you doing
bootleg my [__] cause that tell me is
hot and it's like if it ain't cracking
they ain't gonna bootlegg it like if it
ain't like like I feel like bootlegging
will always be the streets that's crazy
that's your name like that's what I used
to do what made you name yourself
because I used to be [__] you got
busy with on a boole pirating music and
purses and shoes and jerseys and you was
thinking about a dog I mean I was like
16 trying to support it you think about
a dollar bro I could never knock nobody
hustle I was bootlegging a lot of [__]
though you know what I mean we had I'm a
person that don't I'm not mad at the
boot like I was I was The Bootlegger in
Arizona for like two years two years you
had everything oh everything if you need
to come see you you had it oh I shout
out to I always tell us the game but I
would say on the documentary [__] for
like two months before it came out I
made so much money in high school before
it dropped oh yeah I was [__] I had
the CD burner booming
you remember we're the same age ish uh
the picture tees 100 so I used to make
them [__] at the swap meet so you
could just print whatever one whatever
you wanted to have like the [__]
movie which you were selling them for
twenty dollars probably 25 25. but yeah
and then I had the purses I had to that
bro remember when yt's was jumping at
home you can get three white tees for
ten dollars
then you'd be like you'd have like a 50
Cent mug shot too and you could get them
then you'd have a Scarface tea and then
you'd have a mixtape if you want a
mixtape and if you wanted a fake pair of
Tiffany dunks I could get you right
Canal Street man they had I was Canal
Street in Arizona I was dealing directly
with with the lady in China yeah that's
good now they had the Gucci Knights the
the Louis nah [__] that it's Time Square
now too the Africans in Times Square
booming
bro I bought a fake Louis belt like six
months ago in New York and it's it's
holding up nicely and I have real Louis
belts but I got a fake one but you you
cab so nobody gonna think that's fake
also if they that's what people don't
know they found out my name's bootleg
Kev suck my dick this is what I learned
with once you have a name or you got
then they feel like you gotta you got
money they could they could Google you
Wikipedia whatever
you can wear face [__] I just seen
Kendrick he just went and bought them
fake Jordans you saw that yes but that's
Kendrick Lamar so what are you gonna say
and who's gonna say anything to that
ocho singers put on whatever you want
you see I pull up white tea That's What
uh Cinco said he said uh he never bought
any real jewelry because he's like yeah
the [__] that dress up all the time
they trying too hard oh yeah when the
designers wearing them they trying to
they trying they trying to keep the
rapper cost too much they're trying to
keep an image you know for the human
costume Jesus I know so many people in
my life now
that [__] got money during the
pandemic
and they the designer is wearing you bro
you're not wearing the designer it's
wearing you
a lot of designers and if I go in them
stores and I see [__] I like I buy it
for sure but I'm saying like my man [__]
on before I'm gonna go some of these
guys you know what I mean yeah always
been like that like my man got something
I don't care if it's a belt I don't care
if it's a it's a I don't give a [__]
what it is a fitted socks shorts tees
sweatsuit I'm gonna put my man [__] on
put somebody from the hood on before hey
let's stop the interview real quick to
tell you about our good Folks at King
Palm that's right man shout out to King
Palm uh we're talking about nothing but
that organic all right that natural
Them Leafs all right there's no tobacco
involved and they're so smooth when you
smoke in them I love King Palms the only
thing I'm smoking out of now if you go
to your local uh liquor store you go to
your local smoke shop you can get King
Palms of course 7-Eleven's got the king
pongs and they have so many crazy
flavors like shout out to Sugar Shawn
who's from um
Phoenix Arizona my hometown he's got his
own flavor they just sent us these now
what's dope about King Palm is that they
have the the terpene infused flavors so
at the end of the tip of these pre-rolls
right you get the Leaf
you squeeze the tip that's what she said
and then you just get a burst of flavor
this is that honey mango all right now
this is the most important part this is
absolutely natural
tobacco-free leaves the cleanest way to
smoke all right trust me when I say it
man we love King Palm over here so many
flavors I mean shout out to the grape
shots of the honey mango shout out to
the sugar punch right here you know what
I'm saying look if you go to kingpom.com
right now you can get hooked up with
everything you need at 50 off if you use
the promo code bootleg
or bootleg cave try either one of those
I forget which one it is it's bootleg or
it's bootleg Kev you know what the
correct promo code will be down below
use the one that's down here kingpom.com
get 50 off right now shout out to King
pong
also want to shout out to our good Folks
at Blue chewbaby shout out to Bluetooth
now this what's going on with Bluetooth
man everybody keeps asking me this
Bluetooth work yes it works but don't
take my word for it you're gonna get a
month for free when you go to
bluetooth.com and you use the promo code
bootleg a month for free now what is
Bluetooth fellas if you're dealing with
erectile dysfunction fellas if your dick
is not getting as hard as you'd like it
to maybe for your wife oh I don't know
listen all you got to do is go to
bluetooth.com it has the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis but
it's getting delivered to you in a
chewable form right to your door in
discreet packaging and you do not have
to go into a doctor's office to get
Bluetooth you go to bluetooth.com you
use the promo code bootleg you get a
month supply delivered to your door
discreetly of course
discreetly
no doctor's appointments no going and
leaving your house and sitting in a
Lobby and waiting for some you know lady
to call you in so you could tell her how
your cock's not working properly it
happens fellas all right blueshear.com
take my word for it also take their word
for it because they're going to give you
a month's supply for free just five
dollar shipping bootry.com promo code
bootleg uh let's get back to the
interview me and you were in Vegas the
same weekend uh summer league was it
last weekend yeah yeah uh
did you go to any summer league games
yeah I went to what game was that the
Pelicans and Golden State yeah Pelicans
go to state hell yeah shout out to Chris
Paul ran into Chris Paul he showed mad
love yeah [__] uh summer League's A
vibe bro
you know what's crazy about it bro I
always wanted to play in that [__] but I
ain't get this yeah I think you still
could you know I I ain't get there you
know what I mean so me sitting there
watching and it was like damn always
wanted to do the big shout out to my
nephew Man Jimmy Young
play for University of Maryland and I'm
saying I feel like he the chips yeah I
feel like he toss anybody in that summer
league this summer but he got another
year he he he ain't he ain't leave you
know I mean he got one more year but I
think going he going
keep keep that name and y'all you know
what I'm saying and yeah she's starting
this year he'd be starting last year
he'd been killing yeah I don't watch
college basketball until it's like they
went to um he went to Charlotte first
killed there transferred he from DC from
the DC area
that's my sister's son that's my my
message that's my actual nephew I'm at
the University of Maryland started off
the gate and and went all the way they
went to the tournament they lost their
um yeah they were yeah Maryland was in
the tournament they lost Alabama yeah
but he took them to the tournament first
year they went to the tournament so he
got one more season you know what I'm
saying but keep that name you know what
I'm saying just on your Jamir young
Jamil young my nephew my little twins
to all them [__] in the summer I
wouldn't watch this [__] like man they
killed this [__] yeah the summer league
was fun uh because you also like walk
around you could just meet random like
everybody did bro that's the beauty
about it like Steph Curry was sitting
right here it was it was a Vibe like I
like I like [__] like that because I
come from basketball at the end of the
day like I love to rap [__] rap is what
changed my life is what feeds my family
is what I grew up on but obviously the
Knicks fan
yeah yeah
I'm always going with the Knicks over
the Nets yeah I'm from harlemen
I [__] with the Knicks you know what's
crazy is like or you're like a player
guy the Knicks is like you gotta [__]
with the Knicks if you from New York I
feel like you know what I'm saying but
it's like they can never get the
I mean it's the owner the right oh and
we bring everybody to the town we had
mellow we had everybody
I think it's the distractions and then
Isaiah Thomas was running the team I
think it's the club
nah you don't think so I don't know you
might know more than me because you
probably see these guys
nightlife y'all [__] closed man early
over here correct 2 A.M is over I would
say New York City we could be outside
four or five is the club scene booming
in New York right now no
so the club scene's still decent here
though but I'm talking about the years
of the Knicks having Knicks New York was
cracking oh for sure yeah like from the
tunnel and [__] you know what I'm saying
like so it's like I mean you'll be out
so far it's like [__] we lost we're
going to the tunnel [__] we lost
we're going to speed we going are you
still going to the strip clubs in New
York like they were they shut all our
shits damn man like so like Starbucks
yeah but lust is a dub Aces is a dub
like all this [__] that like that we was
really doing on the regular like what we
really was like oh no we got clubs in
New York that every rapper is coming
soon they [__] all that [__] though damn
this new [__] that's opening right now
that they trying to get back cracker and
since the pandemic but before the
pandemic we have some spots how crazy
because I was in New York not too long
ago and it is so crazy to be somebody
who's been going to New York for so long
and how like illegal weed was there and
you could just blow post it's like it's
like people think there's super Paws
people get smoke man no but people think
like La is crazy no New York if you're
just walking down the street there's a
random dude on the corner with a Fallout
table with a bunch of drugs on it in
front of police and it's like a it's
pretty sick like I went to
um that ain't cause no crime Kev I feel
like over time they felt they realized
that [__] like this [__] ain't crack
like crackhead [__] wounding and I'm
saying crackle turned the city upside
down type [__] the bug which is why
y'all pressing us for the bug bro Bud
make you do two things laugh or get
hungry
don't go to sleep or go to sleep three
things you know what I'm saying some
people get paranoid very apparently that
mean it ain't for you yeah I don't get
paranoid off the off the weed I'll be
I'm good off the weed you know I mean so
I'm glad they legalized it like I went
to a store and buy like I don't know I
bought a sandwich or some [__] and like
a soda and they had the weed there for
you too and behind the [__] counter
the dude had weed and shrooms but that's
old school I was like this is crazy
do your homework on Mad bodegas in New
York City it was the bodega energy it
was different
I gotta you know fybj man yeah I gotta
meet cuz
I don't know him no no because I'll be
telling [__] do their homework so
that's why BJ men do this so I only know
him because recently he's the funniest
[__] on the internet right now that's
what I've heard no I'm gonna be real
like I gotta meet clubs like Texas yeah
I got a bump into cuz some kind of way
is he running
watch his interviews bro like he the
only [__] that I really smoke and sit
and watch because interviews I just
thought he was on no jumper no he
different but are you have you tapped in
with [__] Mack
five crap yeah yeah I met Matt you know
what where I'm at where where Mac was
that at my at my uh lemonade I had a a
lemonade event
I dropped when I dropped the East Coast
with shouts and Steve Lobel Mania
eliminated Van Nuys
yes it's uh
it's fun to see equipment but nice is in
New York you'd be surprised how many
spots is like [__] you know what I'm
saying like it looked like a spot like
oh that looked like a well that's like
if you go to but you're going there and
they got anything else in there you know
what I mean yeah dude for sure cause
it might be a cat in there it might be
three Gatorade bottles in this [__] like
man what y'all doing in here man why is
everything Dusty this ain't no store
ain't nobody bought nothing yeah uh we
went to a chopped cheese in Harlem and
they said it was the best chopped cheese
it wasn't 100 first half and with the
haji's yes so that was the best that was
the best top cheese on Earth who sent us
there who's the guy best chop she's on
Earth
that's right neat yeah he said yeah
that's yeah I love me [__] [__]
sneaker solid solid young [__] bro like
that that day you know what I mean and
it's crazy me and him had a I had a
little up and down or whatever early on
but I love what Nick doing bro like Nick
really running around in the right way
representing the right way look good
while he's doing this guy solid you know
what I'm saying his whole team like or
[__] with me um that's East Side you
obviously got uh a relationship with
burn you've worked with burn what is
like something you've learned from
burner
to apply to eastco and you know just
burn them entrepreneurial entrepreneur
it's on the cover of Forbes
period you mean nobody you can't say
[__] bad about burning bro richer than
almost everybody oh Berna is so solid
bro yeah and the fact that
he don't gotta rap but he loves it you
are like that's what I love about him he
don't have to do he's the most normal
coolest he don't have to rap bro he
could do what he do and he don't gotta
rap and [__] he would still be burner
but he loved the culture
um he's tapped in with with with
all walks of this [__] like he on I got
him on the deluxe the book of David I
got him and um
be real my brother from Cypress Hill I
got them on a remix of a record you know
what I'm saying but but
um burners burner Beyond solid bro like
Brenda been been the same way with me
from the day I met him you know what I'm
saying like I watched him go through
what he went through
he fought that [__] beat that [__]
cancer [__] yeah you know what I'm
saying like the sun is blessed I [__]
with burner or shout out to burn is is
east coast like something that
like you because I feel like like you we
were talking a little bit before like I
feel like any rapper if their team is
like competent enough can get a [__]
if you if you have any sort of clout or
any sort of following you get a [__]
weed strain right you should
what made because because I I was I mean
not naming another rapper who has a weed
strain that they don't ever promote but
there's millions of them you seem to be
like extremely uh tapped in and applying
yourself to the marijuana industry and
the brand like is that like
something you always wanted to get into
but it was just the timing I smoke it I
sold it
that was my one of my first hustles ever
right was weed you know what I'm saying
we were selling we were selling two for
15s three for twenties my cousin Chet
had the haze like I'm talking like Hayes
days like you had to go up the Audubon
and get the haze and Familia you know I
mean he had to go uptown get the hay
like so my first like little like twerks
was was weed right so to be able to have
it on a global scale now on some rapper
[__]
that's the that's the earliest [__] ever
to me you know what I'm saying it's
legal it is legal smoke my own pack
anytime I pull up I'm smoking my own
[__] that [__] that we you know we
always dreamed I was always buying
somebody else weed like now I got my own
my own strand
that's as as pain you know what I'm
saying so we all we all smoke in my own
[__] uh I feel mad good explain the
artwork on your new album oh Wes man Jay
Westy from Harlem he's an actual artist
I mean yes he yes he is he's a no he's a
real like he get busy busy you know what
I'm saying painter yeah you get busy
yeah you're different and um I've been a
fan in his work for years a lot of my
covers was like either some [__] from a
photo shoot you know what I mean I mean
so I'm like nah I want this [__] because
when I sat and listened to the music Big
shout out to Young Guru Guru mixed the
entire album wow you know what I mean
like so that that in itself was
legendary like cool and Dre did the
intro with kid with Kid Capri like like
I just when I really sat and listened to
the the body of work that I created
I'm like nah this is this is all you
know what I mean so I had to tap into
somebody that really
do art you know what I'm saying and he
got busy with that [__] bro that's 24
karat gold paint on that Jesus or
where's the actual painting he got it oh
he's got it yeah I gotta buy that from
I'm gonna see you man yeah I'm gonna get
that he sent me and he sent me a number
oh he's he's actually trying to sell he
should give it to you no he's gonna sell
that that's a body I ain't even mad
about it like because you know I mean he
really put time into it right right
somebody else is one of them and and
he'd be kept it really like bro I can't
really get this off somewhere like you
know what I'm saying right now I need
that how much is he asking for it
a couple dollars five or ten or ten
figures a little under ten like 10
figures no five figures a little under
down but then you know under 10k yeah
that's not bad
he could do it for me I got the family
price and it's my album so it's your
album and you're talking about him
giving them all this free [__]
publicity there's a picture of me on
there so you know he gave me the family
price but big big shout out to Jay West
man Harlem he got busy with that [__]
that [__] is I feel like that's a piece
that's gonna live forever yeah you know
what I mean what is your you always have
a very interesting like
you'll release [__]
like independently and then you release
something with the label and then you'll
release them independently we're here
baby
I didn't figured it out so I'm just
trying to figure out what kind of deal
you have because you got I got a pretty
good [__] deal big shout out to tunji
Dev Jin everybody bro just like you
could kind of you'll drop some like
you'll throw like a Milly's project out
or you've put out some like Mick quote
unquote mixtapes right right you know
what it is Kev I feel like
from the person that signed me a Def Jam
till now bro I've been there bro I
didn't watch that [__] like that [__] is
like musical chairs there's somebody new
coming in that [__] every other year do
you think that's the problem with Def
Jam there hasn't been continuity
uh
uh kind of but it's like I you got one
CEO coming and he he sold on your
project he's so long who you are right
it's like you got to resell them on it
every time yeah the next person coming
it's like he don't know me right he
might be coming from a whole another
vibe now it's like typical [__] like you
know what I mean like if your a r gets
fired now you don't have someone in the
building fire it's like a coach bro it's
the same [__] with basketball when the
coach get put to a new team he might
bring three four players with him and
you might have been that guy on that
team already but it's like yeah I mean
[__] I'm a Suns fan you know what I mean
that new owner bought the [__] team
and he hit explode and did what he
wanted to do with it because he owned it
so now we got Bradley Bill it's the same
with the label and luckily big shout out
to tunji tunji um
he came check me in the projects before
nine saw me wow so he was already a fan
through Myspace this when he was with
TDE yeah this is like 2012 13 some [__]
like that before I ever got a deal I'm
in the hood
just putting [__] out YouTube he was one
of them people that tapped in and looked
and and and fast forward almost 10 15
years
he running Def Jam and I'm over there it
is crazy I mean it's been that long
because I think I just I forgot what
Action Bronson album just popped up on
my [__]
I [__] with Bronson we go to the center
you guys were very um similar class I
feel like in terms of like I associate
you guys it was all before me though
like he was out before you for sure but
I just mean like when I think of like a
period of time in New York hip-hop I
think like you him Joey uh you know all
the [__] Joey my brother both of them
are like it's crazy I don't got music
with them why I don't guys do your
homework on me not having songs with joy
badass or action bro you don't have a
song with either of them no man and I
love both of them and I personally know
both of them we didn't met each other
Bob Joey really my guy like
dude I was at Macy's and he's a [__]
cologne ad model Joey was inspected that
and then he turned into
he went to power and by the way 50
mustard through that bag you got a
bottle Wu-Tang yeah we had a whole new
yeah season three originally yeah
Joey was Rebel so he backed out to do
power
that last season it wasn't like go watch
it go watch the three seasons it was
wait yeah he wasn't I've only seen
season one it was me and I only watched
season one it was me and me and Joey
live together he wasn't he was in season
one yeah so I didn't watch I didn't
watch it past season one yeah because I
feel like I kind of know what I think I
think 50 was like yeah we got a little
something more a little something extra
over here come on and he killed that
[__] killed it he killed power am I
gonna lie he fit that role perfectly
like he killed that [__] I'm such a big
fan of The Wire
that like me too you know I was in [__] a
little while I just told [__] I was
watching The Wire it's my favorite show
ever I ran it back from the first yeah
yeah I did that during the pandemic I
watched every re-watched that's my [__]
from the first season like you gotta
watch that whole [__] oh it's the best
and then it makes you appreciate season
two more when they go to the docks
because when that first first ran that
way you were like what the [__] where's
stringer at where's the where's my guys
at it's like these balding white men on
the docks man that's it
great [__] season man
um entrepreneurally what all I mean you
got this you say you got the store going
I mean we're just talking about you got
something coming in Vegas
yeah I just linked up with a new um LP
Exotics you know I'm saying we bout to
we about to definitely um tap in and
[__] like that but when you do your own
like branded dispensary oh yeah that's
one way they gotta do that in New York
right because that's on the way the New
York Runner just did the cookie store on
34th Street like it's it's is that a
weed store
I don't know if there's no weed in there
he's got his clothing so you might could
come get the merch but it's but it's
they know what they know what's going on
like I feel like they're not
pressing that as much as they was maybe
five ten years ago well because there's
not like dispensaries in New York right
it's a few is there oh there's three
okay yeah yeah cause I'm like I don't
remember seeing any there's a few
[__] New York's lit the only thing
you can't do in New York is have a gun
and keep your money yeah don't get cold
with the handling that's it yeah no guns
and if you have money we want it it's
gonna get caught with the with this with
the Amazon oh geez that's it you might
sit up for that anything else you cool
um for you you have obviously a guy like
core day on this project my brother
that's another solid solid individual we
actually went to Towson congrats to him
we didn't go together but we went to the
same school type [__] in Baltimore oh
really and we both dropped out oh he's
much younger and we both doing what
we're doing out here we both dropped out
and they're both it's beautiful
it's so beautiful everything they told
us that we couldn't do we doing here I
wonder do you have to pay for futures
these days like I feel like people will
just do [__] for you for free because
you're Dave East yeah I don't nobody
ever talks a dollar amount with me it's
more about you know the label letting me
know you know such and such wanted this
but as far as me reaching out or me
linking up and we cooking that should be
natural
but every to each artist you know to
each his own everybody deserve what they
deserve you know what I'm saying like if
I know you signed to a major label and
they got a budget I'm on a couple
dollars too like so I get it but as far
as the the the the relationship or the
convo that I have with the artist
I ain't never spoke about no money from
Chris Brown and to to Wiz Khalifa The
Snoop Dogg I feel like yeah whatever I
actually don't think Wiz be charging
anybody
you know where's my brother can you hang
with him
yeah but we're smoke different it's
different yeah it's just non-stop you
smoke a little bit where's had me high
for a couple days [__] with me
because he ain't just you know I mean
like you do the shrooms with whiz nah we
did the uh dab oh the water bong yeah
the water the water thing yeah that flip
[__] yeah flip over and all that so I
was he had me high for a couple days if
you don't you say you stopped why did
you quit doing shrooms I had some bad
trips bro like I ain't gonna go up front
I probably would [__] with it but it's I
feel like shrooms is based on your
environment bro yeah like I'm taking
shrooms in Harlem not a good place to do
her like it's mad [__] around me and I
took this [__] on Fright Night
shout out to Javonte you know I'm saying
my brother so you were watching that
fight on Trump I'm watching the fight
it's it's like 50 people around me it's
a bad move [__] won't take pictures
[__] taking shots it's we there's a
lot going on and I'm shrimped up you
know what I'm saying like I'm on I don't
know where I'm at did you have a bad
trip
I just sent it I ain't enjoying you
freaking out a little I was annoyed you
know what I'm saying I was so annoyed
with the shrooms I felt like I was
supposed to just been chilling but like
[__] was annoying me have you ever had
like a literal bad trip where you
started like bugging out a little
uh
nah I've had a trip where where like me
and my brother one night I ain't going
front
well you know what I'm talking about
looking crying already me and my little
brother Vibes my [__] Arrow where he
telling my arms my world same other same
phone with my brother we in the studio
uptown
and I'm saying I mean I I'm already on
the shrooms you feel me my baby bro he's
sober he's smoking the weed and [__]
like that drinking
[__] it
then he start tripping tripping bro like
you feel me like he's seeing [__] in the
room he don't want to sit down he's
standing up he moving he moving walk in
the in the room bro like I'm not feeling
his movements you know what I'm saying
but I'm smacked too so I don't even know
what to tell this [__] like damn bro
like we both you know I mean like we
floating yeah
step outside Kev it's a monsoon
literally happening do your homework on
myself I'm from Arizona we have monsoon
season so I'm gonna wear it raining and
it was hot chats and but it was like 85
90 degrees bro it's raining crazy so now
we gotta run to the car we jump in the
car
bro I might have did 15 miles an hour
just all the way home bro like but smack
but right and he telling me slow down
you are
I'm not speeding I know he like oh slow
this [__] down boy like you're going too
fast police out here I'm like because
I'm doing like a dub right now like in a
55 I'm doing like 20. yeah everyone's
passing you I think it's just [__] is
moving past me I'm but I'm thinking he
like oh slow down bro like it's mad
puddles
so I fell back off the shrooms girl like
I feel like I'm on streams right now see
but you chilling this is a good vibe you
ain't gonna have a bad trip that
definitely hit the fight tapping you
it's a micro dose stuff [__] Ain't
asking you for pictures you know people
people will microdose as a pre-workout
before they work out yeah I wouldn't
dare work out on insurance I might be in
that [__] way no it's a micro it's a
micro dose oh like you eat a little bit
of course yeah a little bit see that's
what I didn't do [__] was giving me
three big chunks of chocolate and all
that yeah you know what's going on bro
and I I sit back and wouldn't hit me I'm
like man this [__] don't even work give
me another piece
eat that [__] have you ever ate too much
weed
because Edibles will [__] Edibles hit
your your lower body they'll ruin your
entire day Edibles hit your feet eating
I think eating too much wheat is more
dangerous than eating too much mushrooms
I don't [__] weed on it I smoke but I
don't never ate weed I've had edibles
but I've off the fact of me having
Edibles I don't like that [__] it's
terrible yeah I'm good I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm 35 years old bro like my 20s I
tried X Molly if you ever do cocaine
never
nothing up your nose never
sold it that's good I had parties with
it X and Mommy I'll put it in my I did
this with Coke like on some
trying to see if it was what like how
[__] be saying or if it numb your
mouth is real I did [__] like stupid
[__] like that but I ain't never [__]
no Coke I've never done cocaine either I
[__] with Molly I used to take Molly
put that [__] in water God bless shooter
we used to go out and dance all night
off the Molly we'd be in the spot for
hours just dancing you heard War off the
Molly water like I never took a Molly
straight we put that [__] in water drink
the water and just go dancing and go go
out and go dance you know I feel like
that is the most I miss you we're the
mother like that's the only thing I did
that with like come on we'll be in the
cab this before I had a car that you'll
put on the radio I had a couple dollars
so like we ain't getting on the train
we're gonna take the call like let's get
the cab before me yeah oh and like in
the hood they got the um
uh like the the cars that you could pay
to just rock with you all day type [__]
you know what I'm saying you can leave
[__] in there whatever they Park up like
homie I got a couple dollars for you
stay with us so one of them shits we go
to some [__] they have some shits called
um grits and biscuits
it's like a uh brunch
nah it's like a traveling party like the
[__] go to like this different places
yeah okay type [__] it was in terminal
five we mollied up dance five Yeah dance
for hours b or my son Loco was in there
like yeah that was a
I but that was my 20s bro like since I
had kids I ain't [__] with no drugs I
was happy on the lean
was that [__] like I always hear if you
like stop doing lean cold turkey if
you're like very dependent on it yeah I
was so I'm very addictive that's why I
can't [__] with drugs but was it like
did you have like bad withdrawals 100
stomach I've been on the floor bro like
shaking damn cramped up sweating waking
up in cold sweats all that like but I
was able to shake that [__] and I really
I really thank Kyrie like my daughter
like when she was a newborn she'd be in
the bed with me I wake up sweating like
a [__] like yeah what am I doing
you know what I mean it hit me different
with that and I never [__] with it
again it's crazy God bless my son
um sad boy you know I mean like that was
the [__] the the kid that was selling
me lean died like in the last year or
two you know I mean like they found
overdose yeah he found them in his
apartment and [__] like that so it
scared me like Damn what if I just could
have been you you know you could be
[__] doing fentanyl right now and not
knowing it that's the difference at
least when I was taking Percocet and it
was really lean that was actually from
the pharmacy it was real [__] nowadays
this [__] is pressed [__] is dropping
dead left and right thinking it's a real
pill it's real lean like my advice to
all the young [__] smoke weed bro
smoke weed drink champagne or liquor
like all that other [__] someone who
drinks champagne every time I see you
you do not have a champagne belly I look
like I drink shampoo baby we working out
on this side we're going to happen how
many days a week do you work out I want
to get the dad good
that should be mental like it really be
on some like straight shot I might I
might go ahead day I might I might take
Sunday off I might you know I mean
depending on how I'm feeling like when
I'm really in my zone I'm in everyday
same gym as Bronson Bronson Jim Jones uh
oh that's the one with the with the old
guy yeah what's the guy's name yeah I've
seen him on action bronzer great name we
got the same name that's my guy he
trained well you know he get busy in
there but that's a that's one of them
spots he likes throwing the [__] like
the kettlebells and all that that's one
of them yeah that's one of them spots
that's that's that's uh
I love it there like I feel at home
there they show Mad Love
um big shout out to Impact Zone or how
do you uh feel about this coming NBA
season who do you if your money based on
where everybody's at now
who do you think's who you going with
number seven there's a Devin Booker
behind Jersey behind you you know what
I'm saying so the book shouts the book
bro I'm banging sons all day oh pause
whoa yeah that was crazy whoa
that was criminal hey yo
whoa yeah that was out this world I'm so
sorry come on that was uh come on Kev he
said come on
that was a lot damn who looking good
this [__] man I don't even I don't know
man
I'm so high right now
they still got LeBron yeah bro still
around yeah I thought he said what you
mean who looked good pause bro
now you said some crazy [__] hey we
ain't going oh oh that wasn't me that
wasn't me
uh now the Lakers have a nice roster
Lakers uh they don't really know Boston
I gotta I like I like our Boston end of
the year a [__] will I [__] with um
what's my boy man
I feel like can't nobody [__] with him
right now here's the mountain
yeah I feel like ain't nobody [__]
I'm a big Luka donkish fan so you like
you like John marant yeah I love I love
a lot of these newer guys that's just
explosive poles like they really just
yeah they remind me of [__] in the 90s
and [__] like that like you know what I
mean but but Joker Joker different
Joker's different [__] explosive
that's crazy
hey yo oh
[__] out here
it's cool
I like yogic because somehow he like
he'll get split open on his arm like
every game but then the next game healed
he can't [__] with him bro I told [__]
that early like yeah they swept they
swept and LeBron is my brother bro I
love Brown they swept him once that
sweep happened I'm like bro they ain't
[__] with him bro it's over ain't
nobody [__] huh yeah he's a
definitely anal answer for that
and don't let the other four around and
be having good have a good night
Aaron Gordon there oh if they got a good
night it's over
cause he coming he coming a boy night
lane or [__] me joking uh you and
Millie's do another uh project together
yeah we're doing part two
we're gonna try hard man
Pablo Blanco too we gotta go back to
Columbia for that that's like a that's
the that's uh can I come
AJ put that together make sure yeah
gotta stop the interview to say about
our good Folks at Odd Socks baby yeah
shout out to odd talks now this is what
I love about Odd Socks one their family
we love them but also they have the most
comfortable socks in the [__] world
all right now look they got the craziest
licenses you see the Jolly Rancher these
are actually flies [__]
some Dorito socks uh they got the WWE
license which is just my absolute
favorite and then um personally my
favorite is the odd Sox Basics now these
are just the basic socks so these are in
my bag because I'm taking these
I love these odd Sox basics
these are literally the most comfortable
socks in the world
all right these are just the plain guys
all right also they got the Scarface
they got the Godfather and they have
underwear
what are we talking about what are these
2XL Reese's Pieces you know if uh
somebody was gonna wear some Reese's
underwear I'd assume they'd be a 2x on
the size you know shots of the
Ghostbusters
um look so much going on at odds locks
uh what you got to do is go to
oddsoxofficial.com use that promo code
bootleg and you will save 20 off at
checkout all right it don't matter what
you're into they got all the licenses
Coca-Cola you could be a Pepsi guy
instead they got both you know what I'm
saying uh you're into maybe some anime
they got all the anime licenses they got
Naruto they also got um they just uh uh
rolled out the new uh Power Rangers
Transformers all that oddsoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg save 20 off
right now oh my goodness let me tell you
something the best part about my bookie
is not only is it the best sports book
period I mean look we're in the middle
of baseball season and baseball season
is Big Money season if you are a gambler
you know baseball is where you get the
Shmoney all right not only that but they
got the full-fledged casino going on all
right I'm telling you last night I'm on
my bookie I'm playing roulette with a
lady I'm looking at the lady she's on
video she's rolling the wheel it's a
movie all right they got Blackjack they
got uh whatever you're into Blackjack
craps uh man all kinds of slots some of
these slot games are so fun all right
listen everything you want all on one
site mybookie.ag this is the best part
when you sign up with our promo code
bootleg not only do you help us out but
you help yourself out because you're
gonna get that first deposit bonus money
to gamble with immediately free once you
sign up my
mybookie.ag use the promo code bootleg
get the first deposit bonus right now
let's get back into the interview don't
do that [__] Adam doing bro no no no no
all right cool cool cool what do you
think about that by the way
I I respect them bro you're just a
different breed yeah he's uh that's what
Adam that's my God great guy I was
the way I look at it is strictly from
like a fairness perspective if she has
let him [__] like 300 women since
they've been together the whole camera
yeah I mean on camera and off they've
had threesomes off camera tons
at certain point in time you gotta throw
one dick in the mix you know
it's like a trade
the real question is how many [__]
does your wife have to let you [__]
before you let her take one dick is it a
thousand is it 400 women you know what
babe thank you for letting me [__] 400
women you can go get your singular dick
that's something that'll ever feel good
to no man if you really like if like you
feel me you could have hit a thousand
[__] you're gonna be so on that one
[__] that hit you [__] especially if
you know it like if it's some [__] that
well the guy that did some [__] that she
held down you don't know is some
secretive [__] it's like all right
gangster what I don't know can't can't
hurt me but like would you not rather
know though bro point no I don't want to
know why I want to know that hold that
down okay you would want to know
I mean on camera oh no I mean everyone
knows at that point right she you know
she got crazy on camera hey you know
what's crazy ain't got to come home are
you talking about how she ate the guys
come out of her own vagina I don't know
what I didn't see the video I just seen
like memes they posted and so this is
what I would say a whole get I got some
inside information about what that God
is and it's not hey yo it's not uh
let's just say it's not natural
[Laughter]
and and hey that dude that dude is a
like a legendary uh he's a bro he he get
busy bro that ain't no random [__] that
was off the street like he's like he's a
legendary Boom artist he's like the
LeBron James he boom [__] he's the
Boomer not letting my wife boom a [__]
that boom [__] is your homework do your
homework on that [__] that boom [__]
boom your wife bro yeah like if you're
gonna let a dude [__] your wife
is more what's the word like liberal I
guess he's just more understanding
that's the word he's more understanding
I mean they're also professional
pornstar average [__] this is what they
do for like a living they do that it'd
be like if you started dating a [__]
who sold her [__] like uh you know on
[__] Backpage back in there you gotta
understand like this is your girl she
was already selling her you know
it's like you want me to get off only
fans now that I'm in a relationship [__]
you yeah I feel that I don't know for me
it would just be tough
it'd be tough for me be clear I'd be
tough it's not happening I said no I
feel so crazy when Mama just came home
like [__] just [__] just violated
crazily like oh however he wanted like
and you had to come back to me I'm laid
up in here watching Netflix and [__]
smoking
takes um no it takes somebody with a lot
of uh I need like a l orgy on the on the
get back like uh L org with her with her
best friends four five you know what I'm
saying how many women have you had at
the same time a maximum amount uh
I'm gonna plead the fifth on that one so
five yeah
but I plead the fifth he means five
I just feel like at a certain at a
certain number right it becomes in my
opinion it would become probably like
not supposed to be sold not told you
know the Vibes guys but I'm just saying
speaking in generalities
you're supposed to be so big I feel like
if it's more than two it just it's a lot
it's probably a lot
like if you had like five chicks with
you like what's everybody doing a hell
of a night someone's gonna get bored
[__] I'm I'm I'm 36. what am I doing
with these five [__] I don't have the
[__] stamina in me for this I'm like
it depends on the vibe I mean yeah
nobody ain't nobody gotta be pulling
dude it's the vibe the vibe in the
country is the vibe you know what I mean
depending on you know I mean how to
what's going on I think it's the vibe in
any situation with anybody I think it's
just a vibe
uh what's your favorite song on the
album
mine's oh that [__] changed bro every
every few days I love the intro
um
come too far with K Capri produced by
cool and Dre that's I love that I got I
got actual vocals for my brother
bumped and Bully God bless his soul he
passed this year
somebody I grew up with I mean was
around for for for for a decade plus
from Queensbridge
I got it he was around me right before
he died he came in the studio and I'm
Letting Go in the booth and again so
you're talking to [__] in the booth so I
was able to actually use them vocals
from him before the intro for the intro
so when the album first come on that's
that's bomped them bully from the bridge
talking and [__] where that's my that's
my heart
um or would you do any more full
projects with a singular producer 100
I'm already I'm already right now I
ain't gonna front I already started out
for two with Harry yeah I mean how we
started that we got like two or three
records I started a a entire project
with cool and Dre oh that'd be hard
um I got maybe eight or nine records on
a a rap music project
and then me and Mike and keys we just
started um how did I get here part two
I'm wowing right now you got to go with
the Alchemist man man out just it's
crazy I just seen out and then maybe big
shout outs to Larry June very junior did
you [__] dude you're running around
but he had to eat he's I'm a big fan of
what he got going on but he came to New
York I went to his show
got to kick it with him backstage with
his family and [__] like that and
Alchemist was there and it's crazy every
time I see out we got the same and he
like man you know I can't send it none
right yeah I gotta pull up on him that's
one of them like like I did with Harry
like I did with Mike and keys like like
I do with Buddha and Grands they don't
that that's not like a email type of
vibe that's more about man pull up I'm
gonna press play
and we're gonna go from there but me
Alchemist that's definitely coming
better be crazy that's coming uh so the
new album is out
right now fortune favors the bold man
you're gonna drop any uh liquor or
anything all this champagne you're
carrying around I feel like yeah that's
in the works as well you know I got the
weed so I gotta I gotta let's go I gotta
balance it out you know that's coming I
had to I had to build a little situation
for a while big shout out to Brett
Rick Ross yeah shout out to Bel Air I
was like one of the first five Black
Bottle Boys it definitely yeah they
definitely uh held us down for years you
know what I'm saying but I'm going to
now I'm trying to do my own thing you
know I mean I'm on my own like I got my
own weed I want my own
when you go to these clubs and [__] like
that I wanna I want you to be able to
order some [__] with my name on it you
know what I mean do you have any canned
already previously acted stuff coming
out
what you mean like movies yeah because
there ain't gonna be no new [__] for a
while
um
my personal documentary
okay yeah I felt like I've been in that
sign in 2009 Sammy was 16.
we going on damn it 10 years you know
what I'm saying there's so much didn't
happen before that like for my
basketball [__] like so I feel like I'm
at a point now where I feel like I could
really put out a documentary just up
till now like you know I mean where it
came from until now
so I've been I've been definitely
um reaching out to my basketball coaches
and [__] like that just trying to
recover footage
to make an official documentary oh
that'll be fine myself and I really want
to do some [__] where I can really shop
that [__] to Amazon or Netflix or Hulu
or Hulu I think Hulu who has been
putting out some dope documentaries
artists running around with it that's a
tool in itself it's me hitting different
movie theaters you know what I mean
showing the documentary coming with
merch coming with the week coming with
the liquor of the [__] whatever
you said you own a store now yeah from
the deli it's on her 45th and Saint Nick
Sugar Hill to Delhi Uptown yeah minus
the food
minus the food what the [__] in there
One Stop Shop merch whatever okay so
okay okay okay okay like everything that
everything that I embody
so it's it's in the store okay so it's
like a if you're a Davies fan you gotta
go to the from the from the day you
gotta be a fan of mine it's one of them
they're like it's just invited no but
I'm saying like if you're a fan you're a
fan you're gonna love this place the
spot that's it that's a uh
that's a landmark you know I mean and I
feel like that's the flagship store I
want to do one in LA
I'm gonna do one right here I want to do
one in Miami I want to I really want to
take it and
you know what I mean put it everywhere
that stuff shouts the net first [__]
I've seen with his own store in his own
hood
that really inspired me you know for
sure yeah and still the marathon is
still booming man all right I'm still on
it for sure shout out to Black Sam
um
all right go get the album the album is
out
go buy some [__] weed even if it's
not real you did no my [__] real no but
there's bootleg I'm telling you I saw
this bag for sale at a Detroit West Side
Detroit liquor store it's hot it was a
dollar is that I mean dollar bag is that
yeah
next time you got to record the store so
I could you know reach out they had just
this whole [__] wall see what's up
with them people and I remember seeing
your I was like oh [__] Dave shit's
popping Loki cause they got the [__]
bag here that's crazy yeah that's once
they bootle like your [__] is you know
it's official it's doing what it's doing
um go get the album man I appreciate
your time get that anytime brother you
know that my guy my boy Dave East boom
hey this interview is brought to you by
our good Folks at hardean all right
shout out to the Jardin family in Las
Vegas make sure you follow them Harding
underscore Las Vegas the number one
dispensary period all right the craziest
selection of previous premium cannabis
you could ask for plus when you go to
Hardy in Las vegas.com you can check out
all the other cool stuff they got going
on you know they got a whole weed
University happening in Vegas Hardin is
where it's at all right so if you're in
Las Vegas you get into that taxi cab you
say take me to hardine and when you get
there you tell the wonderful Bud tenders
that I sent you and they're going to
take care of you Harding underscore Las
Vegas go follow them and uh yeah we got
another interview coming soon